guest spots from last week Theo Vaughn
was the guest on The Joe Rogan
Experience your mom's house had on
Stavros Chris's Stefano was on Dr Drew
after dark Chrissy was also the guest
and we might be drunk kill Tony this
week was with Eleanor Kerrigan Sam Morel
was on take your shoes off with Rick
Glassman whiskey Ginger talked with Tom
Papa Chrissy chaos had on Moses storm
and two bears one cave was Tom and Tim
Dylan this past weekend with the Yvonne
head on Trevor Wallace flagrant
announced Andrew Schultz's first ever
arena show in Toronto Andrew Santino was
the guest on the Harland Highway taste
buds battle bacon and eggs versus
breakfast cereal Ali Sadiq was a guest
on the Honeydew Roy Wood Jr was on are
you garbage Howie Mandel was on the
blocks podcast and Michael Roland was on
you know what dude